in a previous video we saw that if you
have a system of three equations with
three unknowns like this you can
represent it as a matrix vector equation
where this matrix right over here is a
three by three matrix
that is essentially a coefficient matrix
it has all of the coefficients of the
x's the y's and the z's as its various
columns and then you're going to
multiply that times this vector which is
really the vector of the unknown
variables and this is a 3 by 1 vector
and then you would result in this other
three by one vector which is a vector
that contains these constant terms right
over here
what we're going to do in this video is
recognize that you can generalize this
phenomenon it's not just true with a
system of three equations with three
unknowns it actually generalizes to n
equations with n unknowns but just to
appreciate that that is indeed the case
let us look at a system of two equations
with two unknowns so let's say you had
two x
plus y
is equal to nine and we had three x
minus y is equal to five i encourage you
pause this video and think about how
that would be represented as a matrix
vector equation
all right now let's work on this
together
so this is a system of two equations
with two unknowns so the matrix that
represents the coefficients is going to
be a 2 by 2 matrix and then that's going
to be multiplied
by a vector
that represents the unknown variables we
have two unknown variables over here so
this is going to be a 2 by 1 vector and
then that's going to be equal to a
vector that represents the constants on
the right hand side and obviously we
have two of those so that's going to be
a 2 by 1 vector as well
and then we can do exactly what we did
in that previous example in a previous
video the coefficients on the x terms
two
and three
and then we have the coefficients on the
y terms this would be a positive one and
then this would be a negative one
and then we multiply it times the vector
of the variables x y
and then last but not least you have
this 9 and this 5 over here 9
and 5. and i encourage you and multiply
this out multiply this matrix times this
vector and when you do that and you
still set up this equality you're going
to see that it essentially turns into
this exact same system of two equations
and two unknowns
now what's interesting about this is
that we see a generalizable form
in general you can represent a system of
n equations and n unknowns in the form
some
n by n matrix a
n
by n
times
some n by 1 vector x this isn't just the
variable x this is a vector x that has n
dimensions to it so times
some n by 1 vector x
is going to be equal to
some n by 1 vector b
these are the letters that people use by
convention this is going to be n by one
and so you can see in these different
scenarios
in that first one this is a three by
three matrix we could call that a
and then we could call this the vector x
and then we could call this the vector b
now in that second scenario we could
call this the matrix a we could call
this the vector x and then we could call
this the vector b
but we can generalize that to n
dimensions
and as i talked about in the previous
video what's interesting about this is
you could think about for example this
system of two equations with two
unknowns as all right i have a line here
i have a line here and x and y represent
the intersection of those lines but when
you represent it this way you could also
imagine it is saying okay i have some
unknown vector in the coordinate plane
and i'm transforming it using this
matrix to get this vector 9 5 and so i
have to figure out what vector when
transformed in this way gets us to nine
five and we also thought about it in the
three by three case what three
dimensional vector when transformed in
this way gets us to this vector right
over here
and so that hints that foreshadows it
where we might be able to go if we can
unwind this transformation somehow then
we can figure out what these unknown
vectors are and if we can do it in two
dimensions or three dimensions why not
be able to do it in n dimensions what
you'll see is actually very useful if
you ever become a data scientist or
you're going to computer science or if
you go into computer graphics of some
kind